Well of course,
you know,
China and the US have very different
ideas about intellectual property
lights,
right?
Um,
about copying and things like that.
Imitation,
I'm in a very foundationally,
things that in the u s are completely
taboo in China might be wrong or maybe
even not legal,
but they're not taboo.
Right?
And you can ask yourself,
well,
why is that,
you know,
why is,
um,
is building a building that looks just
like a chateau in France?
You know,
why did we not do that here in the West?
We,
you know,
we might do it,
but it'd be an amusement park.
It would be something.
Would you know that you did?
It was,
you know,
it's Tacky,
right?
So why do we think it's tacky?
Where in the east are considered?
I'm fine.
So,
you know,
you can have,
uh,
a very elaborate,
um,
copy of a,
of a French chateau.
Um,
you can pour $50 million into it.
You can use the exact stone that they
used in the original and,
and,
you know,
and how this copy in every way.
Perfect.
And in China,
that's seen as a great thing,
right?
Like no one would say,
you're kidding.
You spend $50 million on this copy in
the u s we would never do that.
Right?
And why is that?
It's because we have two different
models of self.
Quite the contrary.
Um,
you know,
if it sees something which is great,
it's a small,
I'll do that too.
You know,
it's homage and this goes right down to
the educational level.
I mean,
so the idea,
you know,
in,
in our education,
we're very much trying to coax out of
people,
you know,
their unique vision.
Right?
Um,
it,
you know,
in Asia,
the idea that actually there are many
great ideas kind of help out there,
all around you in your culture and that
maybe before you think about how you can
put your own stamp on things,
maybe you should absorb those ideas.
Um,
it's very important.
So things that to us,
you know,
you just don't do,
to them it's like,
well,
why not?
You know,
they're much more playful attitude and
we'll say toward these things.
And so in order to absorb those ideas,
well,
how do you do that?
Often you irritate,
right?
So painters start,
they,
they find a great painter.
I'm a painter who with whom they feel
simpatico and they,
they copied those paintings and what
they,
what are they doing?
Know we think of copying,
we think of it's very kind of mechanical
process.
Um,
but actually they're trying to
internalize the greatness of this
painting.
So it's to them,
it's not,
it's not a mechanical process,
an organic process.
You know,
they're,
they're taking in this influence.
Ultimately they want to add to the great
tradition that they are signed up for.
And ultimately they want their,
their,
um,
contribution to be theirs.
And you know,
to be singular.
But they see that as coming after they
have master.
They're great tradition,
right?
And mastering it through imitation,
through memorization is completely fine.
And like I say,
it's a sign of Amash.
Now you can only imagine a culture where
there is this very longstanding
tradition of education through imitation
and through copying.
You can only imagine a co two to take
it,
a tradition like that.
And to sort of say this culture at,
well,
actually,
um,
every time you imitate something that's
actually taboo.
I mean,
they get it intellectually.
You can tell them,
but very foundationally,
that's not who they are.
And that's not,
you know,
these are not ideas that they have had.
It would be like telling us like every
time you pick up a spoon,
you know that that's when it's
copyrighted.
You know,
you really,
you really should pay a little fee every
time you use that spoon.
They would just think that will be,
that is really very strange.
Right.
Um,
so I think that,
um,
when we,
we look at these ideas,
we see a very big foundational split,
um,
between the two cultures.
Um,
and it,
you know,
I really,
copying is only one of the many areas
where you see,
um,
very divergent ideas.